if i wanted to sell coaching this would
be a great example the ultimate goal is
impact right it's like how do i reach
more people and if you can turn it into
a business and you can reach more people
i love that okay i'm gonna do i'm gonna
do 50 reach outs today
and i'm going to call the ymca
[Music]
hey
and there she is
it's so nice to see your face how are
you doing
i'm great how are you i'm great i've met
reina is the first time we're actually
connecting kind of i guess we're not in
person but close enough we have the same
publisher that we share cara paulson and
uh i saw you on her stories and i just
love the energy and the vibe and
um there's just a little voice that said
you know what you should reach out and
and do an ig live together i'm gonna ask
her and you said yes and so here we are
we're making it happen
well the answer to how is yes
so
i just said yes and i i didn't you know
really what i was saying yes to but it's
just so great to
to talk to you in person as i've
listened to your books on my audible and
watched you with kyra and you wrote a
book in less than a week
just huge huge props to you and all that
you're doing and the difference that you
make for so many people
i love it so as i was watching your
stories just before we went live and you
said you did something difficult this
morning that that prepped you for this
what was that difficult thing
uh a cold plunge
okay have you done a cold plunge before
i've done a cold plunge yet
so my husband loves the cold plunge and
he's created a sanctuary on the side of
our house that has an outdoor shower and
a sauna and a cold plunge
and every morning i go out there and i
say the hard things that i'm about to do
in my life and my projects my books
coaching all of those things
and then i'm like okay if i can get in
this then i can do all of those hard
things because it is really hard to take
the step into the freezer is that a
daily thing that you do i'm trying to
make it a daily thing as often as
possible yeah i love that that was a
setup for this and teaching yourself you
do hard things you know first thing in
the morning we didn't really have an
agenda for this it's just more like i
reach out and i thought we could do an
id live together what where does your
heart take you would you rather talk
about your book and what you're doing in
healing through relationships or is
there something that i can help you with
where you are in your journey that would
be of value for you either way where is
your heart taking you
oh wow
that is like a hard split decision
uh can we do a little of both
okay cool um okay well let's start with
how it can help what i mean where are
you at what's
if you had to ask a question or two what
um what feedback could i could i give
um i feel like
i'm at this tipping point where like i
have a few coaching clients i'm in in
the middle of
publishing these three books
one uh with my husband that i have been
writing for like eight years
about our marriage divorce and
remarriage to each other
and um and then as i was writing that
book this collaboration book with kira
came up where
that's like creating some momentum
and then i have a children's book that's
kind of about my inner child and and my
upbringing so
i feel like i'm at this tipping point
where i'm
gaining momentum on instagram i'm
sharing my stories
but i also feel a little bit
like i don't know what else to do
i don't know where else to go
in order to do what what's the goal
um
to help as many people as i can like my
message is
forgiveness it's hoping through
relationships um and it's building
resiliency even though you've had really
hard things
and ultimately is it your business model
is going to be the book or programs or
coaches or consulting or what what's the
what's the business ultimately going to
be
good question
um
it's going to be coaching
and i have a couple of digital courses
already and then these books
and you know ultimately
i really love
i'm a born performer i've been singing
my entire life i love being on a stage
um i would love to speak
so that that is my personal goal i just
want to like be out there and be with
people and be on a stage maybe speak and
sing that would be really great
speak and sing okay cool so listen
whatever you want to make money doing
the best content to make is show me the
process of you doing it
so
take all of those things that you love
and now think how can i show people how
i do this so if singing is going to be a
big part of what you want to do than
having regular singing content like
random singing content if coaching's
what you want to do and sell then show
me you coaching
like okay like live sessions with people
like this yeah this is like this if i
wanted to sell coaching this would be a
great example you know i was like i'm
this is it i mean i didn't even didn't
know what we were going to do when we
went live just like hey just show up and
we'll see what happens but this is a
great example of coaching uh and so if
it's about your book is about
relationships right healing through a
broken relationship yeah so you have
people come on who
are dealing with their relationship that
they feel is broken and they need some
feedback and guidance and help and care
and love and your
you know why i
i fell in love with your vibe and i mean
like again i didn't know you we've never
met you before before this
but
your your
just the way you sink into your heart in
the care and the energy is just really
calming and peaceful and loving and i
could see you
i could see you if you're doing coaching
sessions where people would open
themselves up to you where they haven't
told anybody else the things that they
might tell you
okay i don't know if you've already
experienced that with friends or family
or other people you know in your life
but where you just create a safe space
for people to share things that they are
afraid to admit to anybody else
yeah which makes you a great coach
because it's like great listening but
then also being able to give great
advice
and so some people
uh will not want it to be public
you know some people may not want to be
coached on an instagram
video right a youtube video and that's
cool you don't need everybody to say yes
um but
the fact that you're an author doesn't
mean you're going to be a great coach
true
but you are but like people don't know
that right like if the fact that you
wrote a book doesn't mean that people
will think i want to hire her as my
coach
so the best way to get coaching clients
is to show me you coaching the best way
to get book sales is to show me you with
the book and teaching lessons from the
book um the best way to get more
speaking gigs is to show me you speaking
so you start booking
speaking gigs
you know even for free like go speak at
your local ymca or library or high
school or tedx talk like it doesn't have
to be some giant
you know mel robbins on stage in front
of an arena full of people
just the fact that you are speaking
makes me think oh she's a speaker i
might hire her to come and speak at my
next event
and so it's like the more you can have
fun in doing the content and the more
that it actually
in showing the process leads to
a business result that then like the
ultimate goal is impact right it's like
how do i reach more people and if you're
going to turn it into a business and you
can reach more people right if it's like
you part-time on the side doing it then
we don't want it to take another eight
years to like get the next thing out
right right but if you're making money
doing it then you can have a team and
you can invest more in people then you
can reach a lot more people with your
message and your content yeah that makes
so much sense it seems like as you say
it it's so logical okay
yes
why does that not make sense and why
does that not come to my mind and can i
just say the reason it doesn't come into
my mind to begin with is because i get
stuck on the trajectory of where i'm
going and it feels so far away like
i don't know how i'm going to get there
and then i get stopped
so the whole stop steps like you're
talking about yeah yeah so like how many
people how many people follow you on
instagram right now
i think i'm at 1400. perfect the first
1400's the heart is 1400 so you're
already on your way you got you got the
momentum um to my new book coming out uh
the way to do it is to message the
people who are following you and say
you're going to start a new show
once a day or once a week or whatever
you know feels right for you
of coaching
and
do they want to be
your guest where you're going to coach
them for free
where normally they would have to hire
you to do coaching
but here it's
free coaching but it's going to be
public and hopefully in that person's
story other people can learn from them
as well
and some people will say
no i don't want it to be
public they might ask you can i hire you
though to be my coach you know now
now we have a coaching like how are you
actually coaching people now and getting
paid to do it yeah perfect so it's a
good lead in right that you can offer
them the free one on your instagram
but if they they say no they might want
to just hire you to be their coach
anyway
yeah and then you'll get some people who
say yes and then that's how you start
your show
and the beautiful thing with that is you
just have to show up
you don't need to prepare like if you're
thinking about making an instagram video
or youtube video there's a lot of work
to prepare in script and like what am i
gonna you know we're coaching you just
show up you say hey
susan
welcome how can i help what's on your
mind what's in your heart
and
shares and then you go help her um and
it's actually fun because you feel like
what you're doing
matters and helps and is having an
impact and maybe susan ends up
you know wanting to work with you and
hire you to be her coach cool but if not
then all the people watching
as you continue to build up the momentum
behind it well some of them will say hey
that's really cool i love how i love
what she did i love i love this random
person never heard of her before but i'm
maybe she's the coach for me
i love that thank you
and it's just the most fun you know it's
like you feel like it matters
because 1400 people is a lot of people
but it
it's hard to it doesn't feel tangible
right
like that's a small town you got 14 you
had an entire town of people who are
following you
but it's hard to feel tangible but when
you see one person and you see her eyes
like oh my gosh that you're so right
randa and you're a little tweak then
sets them on a different path because
you gave them give her the answer
um
it makes you feel like what you're doing
really matters
right well and that's like that's the
point is to be able to witness and
listen to someone and acknowledge where
they're at and validate where they're at
and then be able to assist them in tools
that i've learned and tools that i'm
certified in like that's that's the
whole point
yeah so
you already have enough people who are
following you
you just video message them
one by one and say hey i'm starting a
new show this is what i did at the
beginning when i started my show i was
on an airplane from la to toronto and i
messaged people one by one to say do you
want to be
my my guest i'm going to start a new
show i went live every day i did it in
toronto so they had to be in we did it
on instagram live but they were sitting
next to me oh cool i had a smaller pool
of people to pull from because it had to
be local where doing this could be
anywhere in the world um and i booked
the first five people
to do my show for the first week
and built momentum
it's scary
but worth it and if it feels right then
the best thing you can do is go like for
momentum you know immediate action like
right after this go book your first
person
for tomorrow and launch a show
i'll tell you because when i i had the
idea on the airplane from my late to
toronto and i was 100 like this is going
to be so much fun i can't wait to do
this and then
come day the day that was a friday night
i was flying back to toronto and i was
going to start my show on monday
on monday morning i show up and like i
don't want to do the show zero zero
percent
i'm too busy i don't have time for this
what if i don't know how to answer their
question what if i can't help all of
like the insecurities and doubts
right 100 on friday night turned to zero
percent on monday morning
and it was only because i had booked
the first people that i had to i'm not
going to not show up like somebody was
in my studio i had to go there and meet
them right so more likely to actually
follow through
yeah
so
yeah if like it feels right then it's
booking your first people and asking if
they want to do the show
i feel like you're reading my mind
because i'll i'm asking questions in my
mind and then you're automatically
answering them
well that then you know it's the right
path yeah and so it's really as easy as
after right after this you spend an hour
sending messages to people on instagram
and i like a quick video message
and just
10 seconds you know hey susan thanks for
following me i'm starting a new show
coaching women through their
relationships or is it just women are
you coach guys too no men too cool
you know but obviously you you know if
it's susan you're saying women if it's
bill you're saying but you know hey bill
i'm starting a new thank you so much for
following me starting a new show
uh helping people through their
relationships if you have any issues and
you'd like me to coach you one-on-one
i'm certain to show next next week if
you want to be my first guest let me
know
and then again hey susan i like i even
do it walking i like getting fresh air
and like walking and get a vibe so i'm
walking down the street while i'm doing
it but um yeah just like 10
second videos at a time to the people
who follow you and at worst it's a it's
a touch point to thank them for
following you
right
and nobody sends personal messages like
that yeah yeah i love that
i like being in people's space like that
with a video it's so much more
personable
than a text
yeah
and and fun and and they'll see it and
and even if some people will say yes
like if you send five messages you may
not get somebody to say yes right so we
gotta we gotta
send more you know like let's put 50 on
our list of 1400 let's send 50 messages
you'll get some people
but even for the ones who don't say yes
you're you're building a relationship
somebody might write back and say how
much they love your content they're
looking forward to your book or all of
these things that are built it's crazy
how much a 10-second video message
impacts somebody
because nobody's reaching out to their
followers and just thanking them
yeah so it's something i do every
morning i go for i call it a believe
walk i go through my believe walk and uh
and i'll just
i'll just randomly pick people who
follow me and send
personal messages
and just i love that
that's awesome yeah and it feels good
it's like it's not just a good strategy
it's a good strategy but it also feels
good that it's like these are 1400 real
people you know maybe some of them are
bots you know maybe there's 100 bots so
it's like 1 300 like but they're real
people those are real people who've got
goals and dreams and aspirations and
relationship problems and all of these
things and they're following you because
you posted something that touched their
heart in some way
and so just being able to say thank you
and reach out um will lead to all sorts
of
crazy good things but especially booking
you know people for your show
thank you
thank you
like that's an easy one that's a
no-brainer and then you can clip the
content and do like you know take
highlight moments and reuse them or take
one-liners and put them up on your
channel um
speaking should be you speaking
yeah like you're
ideally it's with some
at least it looks like it's in front of
some kind of crowd
in high schools or universities or
again ymcas like i got started at the
ymca and three people came to my first
event
but it doesn't matter like you go and
you serve you help those three people
you know action is action yeah
um and then the other one's what the
book or the courses
um
yeah yeah digital courses
so another great thing to do is you have
somebody um
like is the course already ready to sell
or you're working on it yeah yeah yeah
and are like you already made some sales
on it or you're working on it i have
made one sale perfect this is great hey
the first sale is the hardest sale you
know as long as it's not to your husband
than your mom or something
but no that's like that's the great
start and what you can do is um
for the for the early people who buy the
course
offer the do an instagram live with them
too
okay do you know you know actually let's
not say her name but like you know let's
let's say her name was jill right who
bought your first course cool you reach
out to jill and say hey jill thank you
so much for buying my course i hope it's
being valuable for you um
do you want to do a bonus instagram live
with me where whatever questions you've
got whatever you want to talk about i'm
here to serve and hopefully your
questions can also serve the audience
watching too
um
again maybe jill is super introverted or
shy and doesn't want to come on camera
but like at the very worst case you're
building you're saying thank you and
she's going to feel recognized which is
always great but if she says yes then
she's going to come on your instagram
live you're going to go and get content
together and then what's she going to
say she's gonna say oh i just bought
your course it's amazing thank you so
much now you're talking about the course
without talking about the course
yeah so now anybody watching can learn
about oh she's got a course what's the
course all about
right so anybody knew was getting into
the course you can offer it doesn't
scale incredibly well right like you
can't do it for everybody if you're
going to sell we're going to sell a
million of these courses right so
so rand is not going to do a million ig
lives but for the first people come in
and it could still be part of you know
if you had like once a week coaching
from your followers and then once a week
coaching from people who bought the
course
as you start to make more sales um even
once a week coaching people who bought
the book do you have any books for sale
yet or not yet they're all in yeah cool
yeah they they're all slated for uh
september
okay well we're not that far away like
you can even do pre-orders right you
already have the book title do you have
a cover you're working on the cover
i have a cover yeah cool so you have a
title you have a cover
um you can do pre-orders that if
somebody buys 10 copies of the book they
also get an instagram live with you
or 100 copies or a thousand copies or
whatever um and then we start
we start talking about the book right
even though the book's not ready yet
until september
she bought
she bought 10 copies and she's so she
gets the ig live with you and then she's
going to come on and say i'm so excited
for your book it comes out in september
right i can't wait to get a copy so now
we're talking about the book without
talking about the book and still serving
her to help her or him with you know
whatever issues they've got going on
it's just fun like it helps promote the
thing that you're trying to promote and
it doesn't mean stop doing i'm not i'm
not super deep on your content and like
what you've been posting and frequency
but um
are you how like what's your cadence how
often are you actually posting content
right now
um
i'm probably
two or three times a week okay
and does that feel good does that feel a
lot does that feel
it feels like not enough one of those i
have a podcast so one is a podcast every
week um i'm trying to ramp that up and
do reels and
and add more content that way
um so i feel like i feel like three to
four would be
a manageable number for me
a good number and what do you talk about
on the podcast or what's the format
um gosh i have my husband on there um
it's like whatever spiritual message
downloads to my brain
it's it's not pigeon holed to one thing
i love it that's great
so you have the podcast and then it
really just depends on the on the
cadence and how much
you want to put in and how much it
builds you versus drains you um
this is an example
this
builds me
like
today's my mentoring day all i'm doing
is mentoring the people on my team
we've got 40 people on the team and it's
just all day like 25 minutes on five
minute break 25 minutes on five minute
break like into the next person next
yeah but then like two o'clock eastern i
break to do this because it it doesn't
dr i'm gonna leave this with more energy
than i came in mm-hmm you're giving me
energy you're not taking that energy
yeah and that's most of the time like
this i guess is sometimes you have
somebody that's not as great but for the
most part like i leave more connected to
the mission than why i do what i do than
less
um and it's because of having somebody
on with you who
who you feel like you helped like if you
feel like you served today and not just
at home with the computer it makes a big
difference
so
the cadence is up to you
obviously but if you had a regular
series around coaching people who are
following you you know regular series
around people who bought the book or
pre-ordered the book a regular series
around people who bought the course
that could be you know three four or
five
instagram lives a week
it could even just be a regular show
that you go live with and start taking
questions from people that's what i do
like it's just
two o'clock eastern or going live either
instagram or in one of my other
communities two o'clock eastern we go
live and i just set that on my schedule
for half an hour and it's like right in
the middle of the day and it really
works for me for my flow
and then it doesn't feel like work or i
have to make content or i'm struggling
with like what do i come up with next
right as you're helping somebody you're
gonna say something genius hopefully in
some in in this i said something genius
but then we can cut and turn into a reel
or turn into something else right yeah
uh hopefully you know hopefully when
you're helping somebody you say you're
going to say a lot more genius things
that then turns into maybe 10 reels that
you can use for your content and most
importantly doesn't feel like
work and it doesn't feel like you're not
doing enough
because you have your regular show
coming out that's actually helping
people
i love that okay i'm going to do i'm
going to do 50 reach outs today
and i'm going to call the ymca
i love it there you go yeah like the
speaking is harder because you know you
you have to do more outreach and you not
everybody's going to say yes and just
make sure you're filming it you know
that we see you on stage but ymc's are
great school assemblies are great um at
school yeah i mean now school might be
hard but i don't know if summer school
is still doing like assemblies and stuff
but um libraries awesome um any
community groups clubs meetups like
anything where you can basically be
on any kind of stage and then film it
like oh she's a speaker
you know so even i just won a month of
those
um
at the very early stage of my career i
did it um there was a group called
enterprise toronto that's in my city
that supports entrepreneurs
and i would speak there
for like 50 bucks
for an hour and a half and there'd be 12
people in there or something
you know yeah um i did it more just to
serve and to help the community
i wish i had content like now i would do
it for free just to get content so that
i have something for my my instagram and
youtube channels um but there's a lot of
different community like are you in a
decent size city
yeah i'm in the phoenix metropolitan
area
um yeah i mean phoenix is huge so many
so many different groups so many
different clubs so many different
organizations um
that they would love to have a speaker
and just don't be attached to oh i need
to have a thousand people in the room
you know right time people show up
you're there to serve and film the
content so that you have something that
you could put up
um on your channels and i think it's
also great just to show the journey you
know just uh here's where i started
everybody i didn't start
once you're on stage and you know
oprah's introducing you and you know
you're doing your duet with garth brooks
or you know whatever whatever it is
that's happening
uh you get to show like the early starts
and the humble beginnings and
the early stage work that you did and
that was still
it was still just about helping people
more than about i need to have you know
a thousand people or ten thousand people
in the room yeah you and kyra in the
front row of course you'll be we'll be
singing along
cool well i know we don't have uh we're
actually a little bit over but let's
let's talk quickly about your book what
you've got coming up um
healing through broken relationships
like maybe a just a quick overview or
some advice you've got so we can
let my audience know about it
um okay if i could tell everybody one
thing
about these books and i'm gonna i'm
actually just gonna put them all
together
it's that
wherever you put
your attention in your relationships
and how much you put in is what you're
going to get out
so my husband and i were married 12
years we had four kids didn't put a lot
of time and attention got divorced i was
married with our fifth
got remarried three years later and now
we put in so much time and effort into
this relationship
that
it it may not work out it may not you
never know what life's going to bring
but because we put so much time and
effort our relationship is so sweet and
i find that in every relationship what
you put in is what you'll get out so
wherever you are in your relationships
um the brokenness is a gift
because it opens you up for healing in
other areas of your life and it shows
you
what you need to work on
i love it sprinkling the little tidbits
in there it's great well everybody go
check out randa appreciate you book
comes out in september
september yep september go check it out
randa thank you for doing a hard thing
it was how hard was this was it was it
as scary as you thought
no you're amazing you're amazing
i appreciate you coming on i'm looking
forward to your content coming up and uh
good luck on your new coaching show
and there's string in the house my
goodness my first time on instagram i
made it
i went i went to your account and it's
like you you have no profile picture and
there's no content it's like okay this
is going to be fun
that was my assistant's uh that that was
one of my assistant's work so i just
texted her and asked
what is my username
i got it well you're here you made it
you're part of movie makers and you know
as part of uh she joined for a year and
a part of that we do instagram live
together so
we're we're already making progress on
your journey yeah it's great whatever's
on your mind how can i help what what uh
what can i help give you some
perspective on i'm working on getting my
um
medical license in canada to become a
psychiatrist i want to have uh
you know media youtube channel to
educate public about mental health and
wellness
um so i really enjoy your community it's
so positive like i like the energy i've
been here only three three times of your
training and uh really enjoy it yeah
thanks for the great work
cool i love it well you also i can see a
reflection of the ring light so it's
good you got
getting the gear all set up ready to
make some content yeah just a little bit
yeah i i just finished uh ali abdu's uh
six week part-time youtuber academy okay
so i did like uh once a week video and
it unlisted because i need to check with
my college and make sure
i'm kind of following all the rules
because i work for two different
agencies so
cool so so i mean what's on your mind
how can i help what what where do you
what do you want to dive into
yeah so um
and just uh i talked with one of my uh
kind of uh communication person at one
agency and he did a lot of uh video for
mental health and all that uh also i
connect with one of the doctor in
toronto she's one of the famous youtuber
uh dr andrea furlan doing that pain
management and all that so i'm just
wondering like you know uh any thoughts
on like
because my stage is still get going
right like what what's your kind of
advice on you know how to kind of get
going build a good foundation that kind
of thing
so whenever i'm answering this question
it always starts with what are you
ultimately trying to sell so are we
trying to sell your your services hire
me to help you
um one-on-one are you trying to sell
group courses or books or programs like
what what ultimately do we want to be
selling maybe not even right now but in
three months six months a year what are
we trying to sell yeah that's a great
question so um i'm uh
my goal is to have um the
mental health courses online to make it
available for people because i felt like
a lot of
people they're struggling and then
therapists you can only have it like say
one hour a week and it's expensive but
if we can empower people to kind of care
for themselves and help for themselves i
think that would be kind of something
worse uh to to do and it will serve
people well
and so is it just a course is it a
community is it group training what what
what are you looking at selling
yeah so courses like ideally like when i
look at the whole picture ideally like
courses and also build a very healthy
supportive community and also i have
like a huge chinese community that they
need help too right like it's kind of
worse than north america
and also uh i'm always all about uh
train the trainers so i've been doing
some uh you know revised cbt training
with dr david burns from stanford
university and trauma therapy uh with
judy cream from florida and all that so
one of my other goal i'm just so happy
like
you pointed that out is to train the
trainers and that way we have like very
effective uh multiplication
and is it it can be english and chinese
two different languages or just only
english
yeah english and chinese yeah chinese uh
there's only 1.6 billion chinese right
that's just like chinese in china right
i mean and and maybe even just trying i
mean my wife is chinese and uh
yeah
she was uh she was born in china came
here when she was young um
she's food
fujinis
um
me too
are you really yeah 21 generations ago
my my backside is from fujian yeah wow
all right there you go i know so we're
relatives
there you go we're connected
uh but but even i mean even just in even
just in toronto area marcum etc there's
so many there's so many people um
from china in chinese background and
mental health is not really
discussed in
chinese culture
it's not part of that like what do you
mean mental health go do your work yeah
and so i think my north america too
uh yeah true i think it's a little more
open um yes and i think i think there's
a big cultural divide versus people who
are growing up here
especially in the chinese community
people who are growing like i look at my
nieces and nephews who are much more
kind of canadian
culture than foreign culture so the idea
of mental health and like trying to talk
to their grandparents about it for
example it's just like a non
conversation yeah um so i think there's
definitely there's definitely
opportunity for what you're doing um
cool so in terms of getting the content
then it becomes
you know whatever you want to make money
doing then you show me you doing it so
uh
the two things that come to mind are one
you actually
coaching people
and doing
whether they're full-on therapy sessions
um
but somebody's basically struggling with
their mental health and they come and
they do a live session with you and it's
free
with the condition that it's gonna be
made public
you know and not everybody will want to
share their
their story and their
you know their struggles
but some people will because they
they can't afford it otherwise and here
they get access to somebody who
uh can help them and so in theirs in
their journey uh and in their session
other people can learn and progress as
well um
i'm about to launch a new series
with a doctor here out of mississauga um
where he's going to be doing all sorts
of recommendations on me she's going to
do my blood work and do my genomics and
take all these tests and then he's going
to tell me where i'm falling short and
what i need to work on and we're going
to film it for other people to see the
journey as well with all of his advice
and what i need to do
that's awesome um so i study chinese i
was an ob gyn doctor in china in a 9
million population city so i studied
chinese medicine and acupuncture too so
my ultimate goal is to to to do
functional psychiatry and one of my
current mentor is a functional medicine
doctor in new jersey who worked with uh
mark hyman
uh so and also i'm not sure if you're
familiar with dr daniel ayman's work
brain brain work yeah i know so that'll
be uh kind of neat to have that
available for
canadians and chinese too
for sure and so
you know whatever whatever makes up
functional medicine for you or
functional psychology or um psychiatry
psychiatrists
yeah um
you know if you're gonna have them do a
meditation session with you or you're
gonna have them do acupressure with you
or you're gonna like whatever that
whatever
makes it up for you
show me you doing it because there's a
lot of uh
skepticism a lot of fear a lot of oh i
don't know if that's gonna work for me
and so being able to see other people
do it reduces the stigma and and hey
it's okay to ask for help and it's okay
to
to
learn some of these things for yourself
that's
a big reason why i do these experiments
is just
to
i could do it privately like the doctor
that i was talking to at his house on
the weekend he's like you sure you want
to make that
all public on your youtube channel it's
like yeah like it helps reduce the
stigma
you know it helps show that it's okay
great yeah that's great yeah i think
that's yeah adorable
adorable there you go
[Laughter]
[Music]
seriously
we need more people like you
well but but like you know there's you
so you could do it you could guide
people through it so even if it's uh
you know obviously you're not going to
be doing um there's only some things
that you can do
virtual like this but
asking people
what they're struggling with with their
mental health and then helping guide
them they get access to you where
otherwise you wouldn't you know your
your time is limited so you can't take
on everybody especially for free to come
in and you're just going to help them so
you help them for free if it's public if
we can record a video and then that
becomes content
then other people
will uh watch that
and some people will say hey can i be
next can i be on your show i have i have
some like who doesn't have mental health
issues of some kind right it's like
everybody
right
and other people will watch and say hey
i love what you did can i hire you like
i don't want it to be on your youtube or
instagram but how can i can i work with
you can i hire you
and say yes you can here's my here's my
program uh and whether that's one-on-one
that you want to do whether that's the
courses and the
group training or community or whatever
else that you're trying to sell
usually that's easier content to make
because you in the work that you do
getting the direct feedback from
somebody to see that it's working really
helps as opposed to just sitting in
front of a camera and trying to record a
video by yourself
right yeah that makes sense yeah it's a
lot easier
yeah it's a lot easier it's a lot more
fun even like what we're doing here is
is very meta like we're we're kind of
living the example of what i'm
suggesting where oh yeah that's the best
yeah you you sign up for movement makers
for a year
right we hadn't met before this you came
from anna recommended by a friend cool
and as part of that we're doing an
instagram live together where yeah
that's totally surprised throw me off i
found that out at 1 44. oh there you go
i was asking for zoom link and then
she's like oh no
it's instagram live let's go i know
that's awesome i love it and so
you know that that you're part of my
program movement makers you're going to
create your own program whether it's
whether it's
live training or just the package
training or it's the community as part
of it right
but if somebody signs up for a year
right then they can get a one-on-one
session with you as well that then
becomes content for your channel as well
so for me
there was no um there's no prep work
right so i'm not trying to i don't even
know what we're talking about you don't
even have an account right i go to your
account there's no picture there's no
content
who's jane what are we even talking
about today i'm sorry no no but it's
fine it's fine like right this is why
this kind of content is so much easier
to make
because if somebody's going to come on
live with you you don't have to have
them fill out a 20-page questionnaire
before they can talk with you
they're coming on they're struggling
with their mental health in some
capacity they're going to ask you
questions that are within your realm of
expertise
and then you're going to help them
and so it's the easiest kind of content
to make and it's the most fun kind of
content to make because you get to
interact with somebody in and know that
you're helping them where most content
like the thought leadership kind of
content direct to camera you're by
yourself
um there's a lot more scripting there's
a lot more work there's a lot more
preparation there's a lot more mistakes
there's a lot more nerves the content
usually not as good so that's where like
if your goal is to be a speaker
if you said hey evan michael i want to
be a public speaker my number one goal
is i want to be speaking on stages
then
the strategy shifts a little bit now
we're not making coaching videos we need
you to be great in talking direct to
camera by yourself in a room
but if your goal is i want to sell
coaching i want to sell memberships i
want to sell
potentially one-on-one services with me
i want to functionally help people
then
the content should be you functionally
helping people yeah by the way uh being
a speaker is my goal too so you know i
have a speaking and coaching
coach
and i i see him one hour weekly yeah i
think the effective communication is
very important
and and so
you don't have to do one or the other it
just becomes what you when i asked you
at the beginning what do you want to
sell jane and so yeah
now if you're also trying to sell
speaking services
it's definitely possible
it's a longer
and more difficult road only because you
have to you have to keep developing a
skill set to be better at it where if
somebody's coming to you right now with
a mental health issue
you can already help them with
everything that you already know you
don't need any prep work you don't need
to prepare they're going to come and ask
you questions and you can guide them
through a process to help them right now
with what you're good at
should be able to
you know get five figures to speak from
stage you're going to have to get better
as a speaker and that's fine and that's
it that's for sure that's a worthwhile
journey
yeah but that the other one the coaching
or the the one-on-one work you're
already great at being able to do right
now
so you could do both parallel paths
just the the
the coaching and helping people
like this
is a faster path to you making money and
turning this into something versus the
speaking which is a which is worthwhile
pursuing if it's interesting for you but
it's a longer road to get there yeah
yeah that's so true yeah
for most people you know the faster you
can get them making money
the easier it is to stay on the course
you know if it's like it's five years
before they see any money it's most
people quit
they give up because it just takes too
long to make that happen
so
um if somebody's goal is to be a speaker
and they're not great at speaking yet
that's really hard because it's a it's
not just a tactic we're learning it's a
whole skill set
whereas
you being able to coach somebody
live like this and do what you're great
at it's just it's just a strategy change
it's a tactic change it's easy for you
to implement versus yeah
no you actually need to get good at this
skill right yeah yeah
yeah so good to know yeah so i i i think
uh the the personal development is very
important because um a while back i
serve at the campus ministry and to help
the students at the university more
effectively i even uh took a course uh
to become like an international kind of
certified academic coach so i think it's
uh you know i really like um your
this uh goal of serving people i think
uh
that that's very very important for me
yeah
how far away are you from releasing your
course
um that's my question too because uh i
took uh
some online courses including like a
brandon berger's and all that
i never designed any courses so i'm
thinking like that's kind of something
like really huge and you know i i have
no idea my mentor is writing his book um
it just for me like working full time
and taking care of my dad who has
alzheimer it's just a lot of uh on my
plate so i try to kind of prioritize and
stay focused
um i'm learning how to do like uh you
know online courses but i have no idea
like what's the time frame to be honest
got it well in terms of
designing an online course or creating a
book or doing a speech from stage
all of that is essentially
group coaching with no feedback
so
as i'm telling you this there's feedback
i get to see your face you get to ask
questions or you see like oh she
understood that or maybe she didn't
understand that so when you're working
with somebody one-on-one there's a lot
of direct feedback that you get for sure
if you explain something if you're going
to talk about
one of your holistic medicine ideas cool
if the person doesn't understand it you
can
you can explain it and go in more detail
adjust it yeah exactly so that's it's
easier
when you're coaching when you're doing a
book or course or speech from stage
there's not as much feedback true
it's it's much after later like if
somebody went through your course and
like i didn't get it most people won't
write in to tell you and you spend all
that time developing a course so
the idea behind a great course or great
book of great speech is you've done so
much coaching that you know how people
will respond and you know how to help
them get
over the hurdle so as you are are trying
to tell somebody
um about meditation
uh
you'll know because you've done it so
many times
okay
the
limits that will happen in their head
like it won't work for me because of x
right
so the more that you do coaching and the
more that you have people follow a
process if i want to improve my mental
health yeah
you have a series of questions that you
ask to help somebody identify what the
problems are so then you can give them a
solution right
just like at the beginning of this i
said hey
what are you trying to make money doing
right that's how that's how i start yeah
so
for you as you guy people through
a series of questions that's your part
that's the jing process
and the more that you go through the
process maybe you've already maybe it's
already perfect maybe you already
have done it so many times that you know
exactly what people you know how to get
people from a to b like your job if
you're helping somebody you have to get
them from a to b
if they get stuck along the way
then
they're not going to get the result and
and it's on us as leaders and trainers
to help people you know finish that path
so
if you've already done a lot of work
helping people the book the course the
speech is
that process laid out for people
and if you've done it enough times you
know it works
yeah so um
it's hard to write a book
non-fiction if you're writing fiction is
a whole little thing but it's hard to
write a book it's hard to create a
course
when you haven't guided people enough
times through your process
that's true this happens a lot with
course creators they make a course but
they've never they've only done it for
themselves and they've never taught it
and so if you've never helped anybody
through the process you making a course
is not going to be that helpful because
you don't know the resistances just
because it worked for you yeah it
doesn't mean it's going to work for
somebody else yeah it will they follow
the steps but there's mental blocks and
mental there's lack of understanding for
them to actually take the action right
right and so the more you've actually
helped people through the process
that becomes the structure for your
course yeah that's so true yeah totally
agree yeah so like if somebody's working
with you how how many
how many times are they on a call with
you or a zoom session with you or
meeting you
is there a usual process um so i'm
seeing some patients from china and
basically just because i'm helping the
whole family and all that like with my
kind of priority and commitment like you
know working full-time prepare for my
medical license and taking care of my
dad which is a 24 7 job because he has
alzheimer's right so i i want to make
sure i take care of myself too right so
i keep like very minimum patient but
they're very challenging because i do
like a suicide intervention and all that
too so i'm seeing like young person in
china like once a week but uh just one
hour but for me really like um
making money is not something like my
number one goal it's to how to prepare
myself to serve people effectively so i
really appreciate your your your
feedback and advice and all that and i'm
also in a
writing group with one of the trainer at
university of toronto because i want to
be effective in
writing communication too right
so
you know what's important inside of that
is making money becomes important it's
not number one but if the goal is to
serve then then monetizing becomes
important because you can do more as you
have more right i've got
i started this slide before you came on
saying that we have 37 people on the
team right
i can do a lot more good with 37 people
than just me
part-time evening weekends and i have
some job i don't like oh definitely yeah
that's my next question by the way
which is
how to build the team
well you built the team around things
that are making money right so
if if coaching is making you money then
you think about okay what what do i not
like within coaching that i can delegate
to somebody else so like having an
assistant it's pretty easy one like
booking the time with people and the
scheduling and the invoicing and usually
all the admin stuff that entrepreneurs
don't like to do we can hire somebody to
help us do those things because it's
better if this have your time being
spent
either on personal side like caring for
your father and all that stuff and my
grandfather died of alzheimer's so it's
it's
it's
like
like the worst thing for someone to go
through um
so i feel for you um
and then also just time on your business
that it's better for you to be investing
your time talking to people than doing
admin stuff
um for sure
there was a great um
there's a guy called the podcast answer
man who was helping people with
podcasting like how do i start my own
podcast and what he would do is he he
only did coaching
and he did coaching and he was you know
selling his coaching services doesn't
matter how much they were
and then he realized he did one coaching
day where he had four people in a row
asking basically the same question
how do i
set up all the gear like what microphone
do i use and what and how do i edit and
all that and so
he was basically going through the same
thing four different times with four
different people right
and so but that then became his product
true so when you've got people who are
paying you for coaching or one-on-one
time yeah
and then you keep having the same things
come up over and over and over and over
again with people yeah that's what you
then turn into your course true yeah
so
if you think about the people who are
paying you like what are the common
themes that keep coming up let's package
that into a course so that you can serve
more people you can make more money you
can save more of your time as well and
that's usually the best way to do it is
around paying customers
not just around ideas that we have like
oh this would be a cool idea cool but
it's until you get it out to market and
actually start testing it you don't know
it's going to work
but when you're working with people
one-on-one and you're coaching them and
you're helping them yeah whatever the
biggest problems are that becomes your
product that's your speech that's your
book that's your course that's your
community
however you want to package it
um because you know that people are
already paying for the one-on-one time
they always have to turn to something
that can scale
great awesome so helpful really
appreciate that cool well uh awesome was
it was amazing to connect yeah excited
to see you continue to build and grow
and and get your instagram account set
up with a picture and a bio and a little
bit of content
and um and we'll see you
uh next week in movie makers yeah i'm in
windsor ontario
four hours driving
that's not that's not that far yeah
cool thanks for the advice i love all
right thank you we'll talk to you soon
okay
cheers
well spotted
i am on a green screen because my
bedroom's messy you don't want to see it
that's uh that's honesty
the viv joint
the buffermakers is here for a year
amazing welcome aboard and as part of
that we do um
live together so
viv what what do you got going on how
can i help what's on your mind let's do
this
so brutal honesty um i'm really bad at
being consistent on social media because
i'm like a fellow math multi-potential i
load like doing loads of different
things and so i get like really
fragmented i don't focus i don't really
have like a an avatar for my business
because i just want to help everyone and
then i end up not helping anyone if you
see what i mean so i'm just thinking how
would you deal with that from the point
of view of someone who's got a bit of a
neurodivergent brain
and
lives quite a chaotic lifestyle
that was my main main thing
it's a pretty big thing
yeah
are you okay with schedules like haven't
we're here you know you showed up on
time we're making this happen
like oh viv's not here you know since in
our calendar we made this happen so was
this
stressful for you in terms of oh i have
to make sure that i'm here in time i'm
not late
no no no if i'm if i've dedicated myself
to someone else or someone else needs me
i'm there i'm on time it's all good
but if i'm thinking oh i'm doing it like
posting which isn't i don't see it as
for someone else it's sort of oh that's
something i should be doing um i i it's
just not as easy
so yeah if i if if i've got clients i'm
there if i'm supposed to be doing stuff
i'm there so like yeah i've got
accountability buddies but i can't have
an accountability buddy with me like all
the time i hear you i hear so this is
good
i hear you sister and give me the hands
the prayer hands and the smiles uh what
what is your business like who who are
you trying to sell to what is your what
is your company about
so um
i've as you noticed i changed my name
i'm essentially evolving that's your
fault cause i watched i read your one
word book it was awesome so i've sort of
slightly changed what i'm doing
um so i'm a shamanic practitioner i do
like spiritual healing but i also deal
with um i've because i've learned so
much because i love learning
and i'm just coming out of 20 years of
home educating my children
i've got loads of different things i did
so it's basically i'm wanting to make
sure
that
people can find their authentic voice
in a in a world where we get sort of
pulled in lots of different directions
and stuff like that so that's what i do
it's all about empowerment making sure
you're your true self
um finding your sort of purpose and i do
that via spiritual healing and essential
oils all sort of tailor-made to the
individual so spiritual healing am i am
i meditating with you am i praying with
you am i are you doing like what am i
doing with you if i'm a client of yours
how are you helping me with spiritual
healing
so at the moment i do one-to-one healing
so i my spiritual healing is based on
being a core shamanic practitioner so
the oldest spiritual practice on the
planet so it's all about empowering you
bringing your power back in ancestral
healing making sure everything's good
from that point of view um so
yeah that's that's what my training's it
and so
so i'm not super up to date on shamanic
healing so am i
if this was a healing session
what would i be talking to you am i
closing my eyes and your yeah painting
what am i doing so so we'd have a
conversation i'd find out what you know
about shamanism because people like to
know what it is
i'd find out what's going on for you at
the moment what sort of help you need
you know are you feeling sort of
disempowered in certain ways or you're
not finding a true purpose do you feel
something's calling to you or someone as
something happened recently that's left
you feeling not quite yourself so we'd
have a discussion and then i can do
various different ways you can come and
see me face to face but i know at the
moment that's not such a great thing so
we can do a zoom
or some sort of meeting where basically
you just get to relax and i go and find
out the best thing to do for you and
then we unpack it afterwards
so i will tell you what your power
animal is if you've never had a shamanic
healing session before so that's your
own little
sort of guardian angel spirit guide for
the rest of your life um i'll tell you
anything i've found so anything that
might have happened when you were
younger or
something that might have happened which
meant a bit of your power left and i'll
have brought that back for you and we'll
sort of unpack what i did and then i'll
give you some journaling prompts and
send you some bits and pieces to do
afterwards so basically your your job is
to relax which is awesome i do all the
work okay so in that process we're gonna
have a conversation that's gonna take
over five minutes ten minutes half an
hour an hour whatever for you to ask
your questions and get to know me and
whatever
uh whatever you need to pull out you
know me awesome then are you
is that like the end of the call and
then you go away and you do your thing
and i'm doing something else or am i so
yeah this is the thing i can do various
different things some people want to be
nosy
so some somebody might come in to me and
say i want a session with you but i'm
not going to tell you anything i just
want you to go off and find the best
thing to do for me because i'd like
testing me it's awesome i love that um
we can stay on the zoom so you can
listen to what i'm doing because they'll
be drumming and there might be a bit of
chanting and you might want to see what
i'm doing although your job is to relax
or we could set a time where you go and
relax and i do the healing and then we
coordinate afterwards so it depends on
the individual because some people don't
want to be there when i'm doing when i'm
doing it some people do because they're
nosy
so this is one of the issues i can sort
of fit it around what anybody wants so
then trying to explain what i do
is quite tough because like there's
various different
okay but you don't
you know you're going to go off and do
it
and then
and then the follow-up or the call after
would be what so after you've done what
you need to do then then we're
i'll come back and say right evan went
on this amazing journey what i found was
when you were seven years old um this
thing happened to you we might unpack
that a bit and i'll say but i bought
that that soul part back for you so
you've now got that person that little
bit of you back this is how i think this
is going to be really helpful in the
future it's going to bring you more joy
and more power and you might find and
then we'll i'll sort of give you some
little journaling prompts to do
afterwards you can ask any questions
because sometimes people are like whoa
how did you know that happened to me and
i was like i don't know it's my spirit's
telling me so what
um
so
we unpack it as much as you want to
unpack it you can ask me questions about
what i did what i found
um if it was an ancestral thing we can
talk about you know where did i go what
did i find out so it's as much as the
person wants if person wants loads of
information i'm happy to tell them
whatever they need to know if someone's
just like oh you bought that seven part
seven year old part back for me all that
bit where i had that car accident that's
brilliant that's what i needed i'm happy
to go then
again it's all tailor made to the
individual and what they want at the
time first of all what do you call it a
session uh
uh what do you actually call it so it's
like i'm using your language
i caught yeah what do i call it yeah
it's session a shamanic healing session
okay again there's there's other bits
and pieces i can do so it's not always
totally shamanic it can be there's
there's other stuff i do so it's a
healing session let's call it a healing
session perfect healing session good
good okay i get it um
and then do people
come back for round two and round three
or this is kind of a one and done thing
it can be a one and done thing if
somebody wants to just know a bit more
about it experience the magic get a
power animal and then they're like oh
that was cool um
it can be as many sessions as you want
so from a soul retrieval point of view
so soul retrievals the best way to
explain them is like
say you had a car accident and quite
often we verbalize afterwards or i went
to pieces sometimes you leave a bit of
you behind or you went into hospital or
you were repeatedly
like ill and you had just haven't felt
the same that could be a bit of you left
some people call it salt like shamanic
people call it soul parts other people
would call it like energy or power say
you were repeatedly bullied at school
and you know that so soul retrieval
would be sort of bringing that bit back
with all the things that went
and so
over my training which took me sort of
seven years i've probably had about 25
soul retrievals and then i've done stuff
since then
so some bits are massive like if
something really major happened to you
that's a big bit so i would say you
don't want to be doing that very often
because it takes a while to settle
um some bits are small so you can come
and see me as many times as you want
quite a lot of people come back because
they can see what's happened over time
and they're like oh i get it now i i
want to have another session of that
some people just want like the one pan
how much does it take from you
after like is it you can go to go back
to back you're like no i gotta heal
myself and rest and relax after
i would say i probably don't want to be
doing more than two a day but to be
honest i've never done more than two a
day so i wouldn't know and i find them
quite energizing because although it's
me doing the work it's actually
my power animals doing the work if you
see what i mean so it's like i've got my
own little personal assistants working
in the background
i like it cool just asking just care let
me know some people oh it's cool
it takes everything out of me and i can
you know anyway good um cool so i think
honestly the best way to make content if
that's what you're trying to sell and
that's what you
it just listen to the language right it
feels like when you have to just come
and make a video it's
it's forced your brain takes over you
don't want to do it there's
procrastination there's like what do i
say and it's not fun or energizing at
all whereas when there's
when you're with somebody
if it's a client who's who is um really
interested in it or even somebody
challenging you and you say like i love
it when there's a challenge then i do
it's easy to show up you love it it's
fun and so
in general doing more of fun is going to
lead to better results than feeling
forced and stressed and you know so
what i would do is do more things with
people
and this is for anybody who's selling
sessions or coaching or you know you're
just better you're better with somebody
than you are solo
your your goal is not like i want to be
a speaker on stage i want to be helping
people
do you do group sessions as well or can
you do that or it's all one-on-one
with the
like soul retrieval stuff that's
one-on-one but i do have like in the
background i'm thinking of setting up
like a dream group and there are other
bits and pieces that i can do in groups
which is quite a nice way to introduce
people to what i do
and just say
what is your
spirit animal and what are the what are
its characters or powers
so just so you know a lot of shamanic
cultures don't like to share what their
power animal is because it's very
personal but mine's given me permission
so um when i first went and got my first
paranormal well my primary paranormal it
was a raccoon and then over my time of
learning it became a dragon and now my
raccoon is like a little spirit helper
so it's a dragon
so which is really awesome because i can
fly and i can
burn things and stuff how does that so
so being a dragon how does that um
translate into
viv's life like what you should be doing
or how the dragon's helping you
accomplish things
so the lovely thing about the dragon is
i work quite elementally so i do a lot
of stuff around earth fire and water i
find that really empowering because
shamanism is all about um balance with
the planet and treating the planet well
and treating ourselves well and
everybody living in harmony and and like
um looking after the earth looking after
each other and making sure everybody's
got what they need
um so elemental working's really cool
from that point of view like i can tap
into
if i need to be more creative i can tap
into the air dragon because obviously
dragon can be all the different elements
if i need to be more in flow then water
dragon's really cool if i need to be
more grounded then i can tap into my
earth dragon um if i want to be more
passionate and get my blood boiling
about things than fire dragon so it for
me
this is what everybody finds like if i
gave if you got a say a dog power animal
your dog evans dog power animal would be
totally different to say somebody else's
dog paranormal because it's purposely
what it can bring to you and what it
means to you and so it's like having
your own best friend who can just sit
there and go
you've got this it's all good let's do
it
uh cool okay so if i'm you what i would
do honestly is just do
public sessions
okay
i mean this is very meta because
what are we doing right now this is a
public session right of what what i'm
this is my
spirit annual you know shamanic session
like this is what i'm this is how i do
it i'm not i'm not going to go and
change and beat some drums and like this
is the magic of what i do
um and we're doing it public and and so
you
it could be with current clients to
reward them to say hey
you've signed up for a session you also
get a bonus one with me online or it
could be with and not everybody's going
to do it you know some people oh my god
that's crazy you want to do this
instagram and youtube and and share you
know some people like heck no i don't
want to do that
and others will be yes and if you
position it there's two ways to do it
one you position it as a reward as a
bonus so instead of them having to pay
for time with you they get a bonus
session with you and the and the the
deal is is going to be public and
hopefully other people can learn
about the process as well for anybody
who
you know so you're educating me you guys
don't obviously don't know that much
about us i'm asking you know all the
beginner questions to understand what it
is you do and how it works and
other people who might be
on the fence or have no idea what it is
now they get to see it and and now it's
not as scary because
they've seen it right i did um i did a
live session with marissa pierre where
she hypnotherapyed me and put me under
we did that live on youtube um i did
emotional freedom therapy the tapping
yeah um live like i don't know what's
gonna happen but the whole point is to
reduce the stigma around
alternative methods of healing
and stuff
and
if somebody's just
maybe heard the term or has never heard
the term but it's curious you're giving
them an
intro to the world that
it's not that scary you know like hey
all i'm going to do is ask you questions
and i'm going to go do something else
and then come back this is not
it's not like i'm
pulling your blood out or something
right
but people don't know and they assume
and then and we go like radical and um
so it's a great education tool as well
so step one rewarding current clients
and offering them a bonus as a result
for signing up um and two would be
anybody who is on your email list or
anybody who's currently following you on
instagram or any of your
platforms and you offer them a free
session
in exchange for it going like they may
not be ready to hire you yet they may
not be able to afford to hire you yet um
but they get a free session with you
with the caveat that it's going to be
public
so anytime it's anytime it's
demonstrable
like you can show it so it's going to be
you know it takes it's going to be 10
minutes of you asking questions and then
10 minutes of you doing your thing and
then 10 minutes of talking afterwards or
whatever
feels dragons in flow
not trying to like force it into a
certain format um
then other people can see it
and some people will you'll have you'll
have different camps some people will
look at that and say that's the craziest
thing i've ever seen
uh
some people will look at it and say
that's really cool
can you do me next like how do i get to
be a guest
on your show right and the third group
will say
that's really cool i wonder what it
would be like for me but i don't want to
it to be on instagram on youtube
can i hire you do you have coaching
sessions do you what do we even call it
right and you say well yes yes and
here's how we do it i do
and that's
for someone like you
gonna be a lot easier
because all you have to do is show up
and and you get to feel the energy and
see the person in front of you and and
feel like you're actually helping them
as opposed to
blocking time in your calendar and
forcing yourself to just sit in front of
a camera and press record and make a
youtube video and it feeling
awkward and
not the right energy
no
so that's that's what i would do um and
i i love helping like that's why we have
this too i love helping people i love in
this i didn't know what we were talking
about
you know there's no
like you don't need
you don't need to do hours of prep work
on the person
they're gonna show up you're gonna
how can i help you're gonna ask the
questions you ask and you're going to do
your thing
so it's a lot easier to prepare but not
it's a lot easier to do the content
because there's no preparation versus a
youtube video with a script and you're
preparing and it feels awkward and yeah
i can't do those anyway because my my
neurodivergent thing is i can't remember
things and you can tell if i'm if i
practiced it it just doesn't
it doesn't have that bump so yeah that's
cool
so when i i mean i did a daily i mean i
still almost do a daily should we do
three times a week on instagram and then
i do a facebook live once a week and um
mover makers obviously is live inside a
group um
when i decided to do this
i
i was on an airplane from la to toronto
and i booked the first five guests from
my show it was friday night
i was flying back and monday i was gonna
start my show and i i just messaged
people on instagram hey i'm starting the
show
live on instagram
every day at two o'clock eastern uh just
answering questions and helping people
do you want to be a guest
on my show on monday and then i booked a
tuesday and a wednesday and free like
they weren't paying me to do it
uh and
the people i picked all said yes but
people could say no too and it's like no
i mean i'm not comfortable awesome we're
not trying to force people into
uncomfortable situations but a lot of
people will say yes
and it's an incredible value for them
and people who are watching along
one is education to to
showcase what it is that you do and how
valuable it is uh and two it's lead
generation client generation for you
because some people will watch it and
then want to work with you or take the
next step to be able to do something
with you yeah cool
so that's what i would do i would i
would look at whoever's so you look at
instagram followers email list you don't
have to have a giant
list like all you have to do is even if
you're going to do a daily show
you need five people for next week
that's true if you just message them and
say hey i'm doing and then if you're
struggling for the next week maybe you
do round two or round three with
somebody
until you start building up
the presence right so
yeah um at some point it just takes over
like if you didn't show up today because
of whatever something happened internet
goes down or
yeah we we screw up our time zones or
whatever there's other people who would
want to come live with me right now who
are requesting right
yeah that would be taking over if they
know hey every day at five o'clock viva
is going live
you book your first guest but afterwards
other people will just
say hey
pick me if you keep doing it
consistently
um and if it comes off as fun right like
that was paying more attention to your
energy and the language you're using
because the strategy has to be a good
fit and it feels like it's a lot more
fun for you to do that and whenever you
can make it fun
you're way more likely to follow through
on it
and it's more fun so why not do things
that are fun right i mean this is why we
have totally agree
more fun than like forcing us to do we
already have enough stuff we are forced
to do pay taxes and do accounting and
all that stuff you know so the actual
work the content creation should be fun
um
yeah so
like i would
start today i would book even if you
want to start tomorrow or friday or
monday start booking people
to do sessions with and give it a couple
weeks of
regular sessions and see how the vibe is
but i think it'll be a good um
i think that's your best path instead of
making
talking head
viv the camera yeah yeah
yeah cool
i like that idea
good
and this i mean
for anybody who does but
some people love being the speaker and
they love just direct to camera
and talking and they love seeing
themselves on stage cool other people
are are much more comfortable and have
more fun with somebody because there's
the energy transfer and seems like i
want to help i want to serve i want to
there's a human and even though we're
you know in different countries
but yeah
connect and see and help um and if
that's the vibe then then leaning in on
that so
amazing good luck on the show and
honestly i just start
i would take the
rest of today and just book
your first five people for your show to
do free sessions with
and once you've committed to them now
you're going to show up and do it
because he said you're going to show i
it's a lot easier to keep the train
rolling once you've built a little bit
of momentum
yeah awesome
cool all right thank you man good job
thank you
if you want to see me coach another
entrepreneur check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there teach kids how to learn i think
it's the most important than teaching
them what to learn i think the actions
speak a lot louder than the words
what does the ideal school or education
look like